convicted boston marathon obama received
a stimulus check of 1400 back in march
now this shouldn't surprise anyone
though democrats cleared the path for
this to happen after they brushed off in
an amendment to biden's american rescue
plan that would have blocked convicted
inmates from getting stimulus checks in
the first place here now former white
house deputy chief of staff and fox news
contributor carl rose so carl i
i want you to weigh in on this because i
know you you study politics you you
track these races and it looks like 2022
is going to be a bloodbath looks like no
matter who's going to be the president
whether it's joe biden or or if kamala
has somehow become president the
republicans are going to get some major
gains so what are they going to do with
that power because there's a lot of
folks in the audience a lot of people
within the republican base that feel
like the leaders are fighting for them
yeah well i'd say two things you've got
two issues here first let's take the
issue of
the democrats and the stupidity of
saying the uh boston marathon bomber
ought to get uh ought to get a stimulus
check
this problem emerged last year
in 2020 excuse me in 2020
under president trump we we passed
relief to people and come to find out
because of the way that bill was written
that we found out after the fact that
people who were in prison got checks and
this became a big kerfuffle and so when
they got ready to
to pass a similar round of stimulus
checks in 2021 we already knew that this
had happened and so
the the amendment was offered by the
republicans and every single democrat
voted against it and why because dick
durbin stood up and said well we don't
want to hurt the families of
the the people in prison we by denying
them a check we're going to deny their
family check as if the people in prison
were automatically going to give their
money to their you know whatever their
their spouse their kids their whatever
so
this was a stupid vote and why the
democrats made that made their members
vote for it now now you're going to have
mark kelly in arizona and warnock in in
in georgia having to go home and defend
giving money to the boston marathon
bomber
as part of the coveted relief
they're in jail what are they what are
they going to spend that money on more
commissary privileges so anyway why the
democrats do things like this is beyond
me but it is stupid but the second issue
is one where we better make certain
those of us who are conservatives and
republicans but better make certain that
their party and its candidates get their
act together virginia shows us the way
glenn young could one not by simply
saying
look how bad boden is doing it he had an
agenda that said here's what i'm going
to do to improve the economy to crack
down on crime and to make it and to
elevate the education of our kids so
whether it's the economy whether it's
inflation whether it's government
spending whether it's foreign affairs
whether it's
immigration republican candidates better
have a concrete idea of what they want
to do and share that with the voters in
their states and their districts
otherwise we're not going to win as many
republicans will not win as many
victories as they would otherwise
receive carl seems like the ground game
is going to be essential you know i was
in virginia two months before the
election didn't look like it was going
junkin's way it really didn't you were
talking with people they didn't know who
he was uh but he continued to to to go
out there talk with voters about the
issues that mattered to them it wasn't
just crt it was the fact that the
parents wanted more control of the
education they were taught about their
kids being in mass or being at home and
that mattered to them but if you're not
talking to the voters
you really can't make that case to them
yeah absolutely i happen to have a
conversation with
the candidate and i believe it was early
october he'd been down on the tidewater
the night before for a big rally and
that morning he began at an historically
black college in in the tidewater and
met with met with the president of
university and then met with a bunch of
students what was the number one issue
the students wanted to talk about
i'm getting an engineering degree why do
why is it that i can't find a job here
in virginia why do i have to go
interview for jobs outside of the state
when i want to stay here i want to start
a small business and i've looked into it
why is it so difficult to start a small
business in virginia and he had answers
because he thought about three big
issues and made his entire campaign
about jobs crime and education yeah it
could be so simple if republicans just
listen to their voters carl thanks so
much for your analysis
you bet hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else